Oh
that's what my mom got a thousand my
mama houses black Jesus my dad cry mommy
at graduation and rocks to it
well this is not happening
I'm your host Roy Wood jr. we all have
that special woman in our life the one
we like to put up on a pedestal finger
sandwiches boy oh thank you mom go make
it rain
[Applause]
now make sure you separate the ones from
the five no no I gotta pick up the money
decorate the Beals to make it rain
that's my boy you know it's made from
his work on The Daily Show with Trevor
Noah
Roy Wood jr.
[Music]
I love my mom but my mom hates
everything like whatever it is my mom
has the gift like most mothers to just
find the flaw and whatever you think is
perfect it doesn't matter what it is it
matter if it's a food television
whatever your outfit she will break it
down and find the one thing I told my
mom to see the movie gravity
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney
beautiful film woman lost up there in
space trying to figure out how to get
back down to earth I take my mom to see
this oscar-winning masterpiece we're
walking out the theater she boils it
down to one sentence it's just a movie
about a bitch flipping and crying
[Applause]
beautiful internal struggle the desire
to live against a bitch flipping she
cried which wouldn't be flipping if she
stopped crying stop crying
I figure out why you flipping and then
you stop flipping bitch stop living
that's what my mom does the things I'm
not like she hates everything I can't
even explain to you how much she can
favorite comedian I'm not even in her
top five it's not even a lot like I
don't curse enough that was her note to
me as a performance you don't person uh
whew ain't no Katt Williams I tell you -
my mom is Mount Rushmore of comedy is
Ron White Katt Williams Wanda Sykes and
bearly Chris Rock because he walks too
damn much that's what she said
why he gotta walk back and forth while
he tells a joke kenji stands to sear on
white I like Ron white cuz he stands
still so you can hit a joke he stands
still cuz he's drunk Joyce that's why he
doesn't walk
she loves Rod Stewart though never heard
us say a bad word about Rod Stewart my
momma got a ton of favorite musicians
she liked all the Hall of Fame black
people but it's something about Rod
Stewart I don't know what it is she
loves that dude like my mama died that's
what I'm playing at her funeral I'm
gonna put an Amazon echo next to the
casket Alexa play mama funeral me my mom
likes Rod Stewart she has all his albums
she loves Rod Stewart she what the New
York her and her girlfriends every year
they go to New York and they go on this
big theater hop into it a blackout for
days and they go watch like 8 9 Broadway
musicals they get one in the morning one
in a evening some sort of old lady
Coachella I don't know what yeah but you
know you bought hop like they do that
but with theater shows in Times Square
so they leave on a show one night and my
mom calls me just just just breathe it
into the phone which is scary when you
get a call from a loved one and all you
hear is breathing you don't know if
there's good news or a kidnapping you
don't know I asked the phone I go hello
I'm just
I met Rod Stewart and we talked about
his career and he asked me about my job
and he told me about all those projects
that's good I gotta call you back
my mama met Rod Stewart took the picture
with him took the picture home put it on
top of the fireplace like I don't know
where you from but down south that is
the most sacred place for a picture to
be put above the fire he went straight
to above the fireplace you're supposed
to earn the fireplace you're supposed to
work your way up you got to be on the
end table in the hallway for a little
while you do good then you get promoted
to the top of the piano and you either
die or graduate from college and you get
above the fireplace and that's what mom
got at the house at my mama house is
black Jesus my dad grandma me at
graduation and Rod Stewart
and she loves Rod Stewart I get home a
couple weeks after this whole went
down
I'm not going look at the picture and I
start peeping some discrepancies in the
photo first of all there's a knife and
fork in the background we're you in the
theatre that is a knife and fork
there's some red and white like
wallpaper you took this picture at TGI
Fridays and she said yeah that's where I
met Rod Stewart I said I'm pretty sure
rights to it ain't swingin by TGI
Fridays to knock out some
endless appetizers that's how I rods do
it rolls and I go give me some more
details of the story tell me what were
you saw him well he walked in and he was
walking around girl who was with them
nobody well this definitely will stop
Rod Stewart you telling me Rod Stewart's
just TGI Fridays prime stuff just if you
like Daniels head you like a chicken
[Laughter]
baby eat it now what this is not Rod
Stewart mama we argued back and forth
about this his Rod Stewart I go by
my I really think this is a Rod Stewart
impersonator I think you got tricked
you're in Times Square it's a lot of
people dressing up like celebs and they
charge money for you to take a photo oh
he didn't charge me I was like what
which made me even more upset because
now I know for sure this person is crazy
whoever this person is this
impersonating Rod Stewart is doing it
for free
this do
wakes up everyday and puts on the rods
do it but on the mullet and a sequin
jacket and just walks through
family restaurants tricking people what
kind of sick bastard I understand being
an impressionist but do it for money do
it because you got a talent but just to
do it so you can take your selfies with
60 year old women s foul some creepy-ass
behavior man lovely and my mom we still
going back and forth about it
he is rights do it y'all just don't want
to acknowledge the fact that I met Rod
Stewart now jealous so I laid down the
gauntlet and I print up a picture of
rods to it
the real rods do it and I bring it into
the kitchen and I lay it down on the
counter next to the TGI Fridays rods to
it it I laid the real Rod Stewart here
and then next to him was Jack Daniel's
chicken and shrimp rods to it and my
momma looks at the pictures and then a
face dropped and
[Laughter]
you evil as over there my mama's
sad are you laughing
and I felt bad I legitimately felt bad
because the truth of the matter is it
didn't matter if it was Rod Stewart and
I she believed it was Rod Stewart the
made her happy let her have a
moment but I was so determined to be
right that in the process
I hurt my mom's feelings and thankfully
it would be a couple years but I got a
shot at redemption because I did some
shows in London and my mom asked me you
know never been to England can I roll
with you and I was like you know it
you a good wingman let's roll go to
England and we're in this department
store in London called Harrods haratz of
London it's one of the most prestigious
department stores it's like nothing you
there's nothing in America that even
compares to it I don't even know how to
put it into words it's like take the
biggest shopping center you know and on
top of that put another shopping center
and then on top of that put luxury goods
and on top of that put a pet store and
then on top of that put a grocery store
like you can get everything in the store
it's just a prestigious asshole like
there's floors of this place where it's
just literally $20,000 dresses that's
every rack it's just $20,000 dresses
like you get off the elevator you just
like this is not my floor but me and my
mom got a pastime that we do together we
go and we look at we can't afford
so we own the expensive dress floor and
my mom was looking at all these gowns or
whatever and one of the sales associates
from Harrods comes over talks to me and
my mom she goes I parted they were gonna
happen first of all my British accent is
horrible
and accent saying what I do all right
now part of me we're gonna have to ask
you politely to leave yeah so at first I
thought it was on some racial first
y'all did Oprah Winfrey like that buy
one of these dresses this happen oh btw
comicview you know how much water just
making up credits arguing with this lady
and she goes no no no no you're welcome
to come back in a couple of hours yet
but we have a we have a shopper who has
reserved this entire floor to shop with
a little bit of privacy can afford to
reserve to $20,000 dress floor she just
rots do it and I turned to my mom she
heard it she had this look on her face I
can't I don't even know how to describe
this look but it's when you see the toy
you really want for Christmas and you're
trying to get your mom and that's how my
mama like Denzel before he cries and
movies
oh I got you Joyce
I got you I turn over see Rod Stewart
approaching Rod Stewart looks exactly
how you think he looks in person
amazing
didn't touch the floor I like your body
I get it now here's all breeze you got a
rich you got to be to have a breeze that
precedes you make ice melt rocks to it
before I saw him
Rod Stewart is 30 feet off of me his
security detail is 10 feet ahead of him
and I'm trying to figure out how i'ma
get through these dudes and I
try and he goes no mate I ain't even
open my mouth yet security dude it says
no mic I gonna listen man I don't know
how to explain this to you but that's my
mama over there she's a huge fan I said
no Mike keep it moving yeah all right no
worries
that's the trick British people do
say something up to you then they
say no worries right behind
and I'm like no bitch yes worries yes
worries I have worries let me skip a
little testy between me and us dudes
already know to pitch ain't gonna happen
cuz I'm an asshole at this point and and
it rots to his defence this dude is in
full family mode this is not the time to
disturb anybody while they're out
shopping they do literally reserved an
entire floor so he could avoid
like me so I understand I
wasn't mad at him but we locked eyes for
a second for a brief second for three
seconds I was I to I with the only thing
my mother has never spoken negatively
about and I know I'm not getting the
picture so I just said amen
did you ever eat at a TGI Fridays in
Times Square
I told you that what rats do it wholly
would journey